her bear in mind we're not trying to
promote well I'm not trying to provide
promo unhealthiness if you watch my tick
tocks in my Instagram I'm dancing I'm
acting if you're even on my screen if
you're over if you're overweight and you
accept that then you're accepting like a
higher risk for diabetes you're
accepting a higher risk for early okay
you're accepting a higher risk for a
party I'm gonna expect something like
you have all these okay okay so for
example and and the thing is like you're
oh wait wait wait so and and the thing
is like your families are the ones that
are gonna have to take care of you if
you can't take care of yourself if you
get too big so it like then it's not
just your problem it becomes other
people's problems